-Our first guest tonight is
the United States senator
from Vermont.
Please welcome back to the show
Senator Bernie Sanders.
How are you, Senator?
-I'm great, Seth. How are you?
-I'm hanging in there.
I want to thank you.
Back in 2020 -- March 2020 --
our first show
that we did remotely,
you were my first guest then.
You were very dependable
in our time of need.
So I'm mostly just disappointed
we keep having times of need,
but thank you for continuing
to show up for us.
-My pleasure.
-We just went through
a time of the year
where a lot of people
have vacation,
took a little time off.
You don't strike me who uses
their down time to relax.
-Well, you know,
in a sense, I don't.
You know, these are, Seth,
really tough times
for our entire country.
You know?
I think maybe the most difficult
times in our lifetimes,
and we got to recognize that.
And I'm a senator.
I got work to do,
and I've got to do it.
You know, I think
this COVID thing
is driving everybody crazy.
I know you have to deal with it
yourself
and were worried about the kids
and worried about isolation
and mental health and stress
and jobs and everything else.
You know, we're fighting now
to preserve American democracy.
Hopefully, there will be a vote
in the Senate in a week
which will override Republican
efforts to suppress the votes
and impose
extreme gerrymandering.
And we got to deal
with climate change,
and we got to deal with
oligarchy
and income and wealth
inequality.
So, you know, these are
tough times for the country.
And I think, hopefully,
we're gonna get over this crisis
sooner than later
and move this country in a
direction that it has to go.
-One of the toughest things
facing Democrats is
a razor-thin margin.
Not a lot of wiggle room
within your caucus.
Joe Manchin, obviously, has
an outsized influence
with what is or isn't
going to get passed.
Build Back Better -- Democrats
failed to pass it.
It doesn't seem like Joe Manchin
has a lot of interest
in working on it anymore.
Is it now officially dead?
We've heard, a lot of times
over the past year,
that it was dead.
Is now there any optimism
on your end?
-Well, this is
one of the issues
where we have got to involve
the American people
in doing exactly what they want.
You know, nobody knows what's
in Build Back Better.
You know, they see a big word
out there, a phrase.
But what it is about is
finally demanding
that the wealthiest people
in this country
start paying
their fair share of taxes.
Overwhelming support for that
in the midst of income and
wealth equality.
We want to lower the cost
of prescription drugs,
'cause we pay the highest prices
in the world.
People say, "Do it!"
We want to expand Medicare
to cover dental, hearing aids,
eyeglasses.
Overwhelming support.
Child care, climate change,
and the need to create
millions of jobs
as we transform
our energy system.
Affordable housing,
making schools more affordable.
So, all of these issues
are enormously popular,
and what we have got to do
is create a resonance
with the American people
that demands Joe Manchin
and Kyrsten Sinema
and everybody else,
not to mention Republicans,
start doing
what the American people want,
rather than what
wealthy campaign contributors
or the big-money interests
wants.
Seth, one of the things that has
really not been talked about
by the media very much, which
is really quite extraordinary,
is that
the big-money interests --
and I'm talking about
the drug companies,
the insurance companies,
the fossil-fuel industry,
and the very wealthy --
are spending
hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars right now
to make sure that Congress
does not do
what the American people
want them to do.
And that talks about
a corrupt political system,
but it also talks about
the need for the American people
to stand up and demand
that Congress represent
their interests
and not just the 1%.
-I know you've spent
a lot of time
in a state like West Virginia.
And I think an argument
can be made
that Joe Manchin understands
the voters of that state
really well,
to be a Democratic senator
in a state that voted so
overwhelmingly for Donald Trump
even though these are things
that would undeniably benefit
the voters of West Virginia.
How do you try to influence
someone
who turns around and can say,
"Trust me,
I know how this state works
better than the rest of you"?
-Well, I'm sure he does know
his own state very well.
In 2016, when
I was running for president,
I think I won
every county in that state.
And you got to,
in West Virginia --
I know that state
a little bit --
and you got a state which is
really struggling economically.
It's an older state.
It's a state where, you know,
you have one economic crisis,
the opioid crisis,
after another.
So, if you're asking me,
point blank,
do I think that the people
in West Virginia
want to expand Medicare to cover
dental, eyeglasses,
and hearing aids,
I think they do.
Do they want to make sure
that the wealthy start paying
their fair share of taxes?
Yeah, I believe they do.
They got childcare crisis.
They got the whole same problems
that every other state
in this country faces.
So why Senator Manchin
holds the views he does,
I'm not quite sure.
But to be honest with you,
I do not think that they reflect
where the working families
of West Virginia are.